Germany and the u.s. an alliance of
equals in the interview director of the
American Academy in Berlin Gary Smith
Gary Smith President Obama will shortly
be arriving here in Berlin it will be
his first official state visit as it
were to Berlin since he first took up
office back in 2009 from your
perspective as director of the American
Academy what can you tell us about why
it's taken so long of course I am no
real insight in this but it it's it's
not really an issue that it's taken so
long because important symbols are all
there Chancellor Merkel was the first
European head of state that it received
in Washington and gave a state dinner
for that there was a lot of competition
for that position and there's no
question that she was is in his eyes the
most important head of state in Europe
and any shorter than that way he showed
it by giving her the medal of freedom
which is an extraordinary you know
statement absolutely of admiration even
it was also also a diplomatic gesture
and you know I think the the news of
their you know fractious beginnings the
relationship if that's even true our
long history they have had a very
intense exchange through the all the
insecure period of the euro crisis
direct exchange as well as the most
intense exchange among a broad range of
ministries and high-level diplomats and
bureaucrats that I've seen in the you
know 27 years I've lived here it's very
interesting what you're saying they're
interesting insights that of course for
all European countries the relationship
with the USA with Washington is very
important the Brits for example always
talk about their special relationship
with the United States based on language
but also on shared values given what
you're saying would you say that germany
and the united states have a special
relationship they do even though the
Germans can't believe it and they keep
asking
neurotic Lee you know do you still care
about us we see that you're turning to
its Asia I mean we can do two things at
one time when can in fact the United
States has do many things at one time
because it has been for a period the
world's only superpower and the United
States takes its responsibilities to the
extent that it can you know deploy
resources far beyond what any other
country in the world does even considers
doing it take seriously now of course
there is a special relationship to Great
Britain I was speaking of the continent
and and the eurozone it's just very
clear okay let's talk about President
Obama himself the last time he was here
he was not the president he was a
presidential candidate a candidate who
stood for hope who stood for change who
stood for audacity what does he stand
for now that's you know he stands for
what every president at the beginning of
his second term stands he stands for
pragmatism for somebody who is trying to
articulate a strategic vision whether
it's a grand strategy I doubt but but a
strategic vision and deploy partners to
help implement this vision in the case
of Obama and this is just my own
personal conjecture it's clear to most
Americans on both sides of the aisles
that United States cannot even cannot
fulfill the role that has been given to
it of you know the worlds of taking
responsibility for everything and so
given the rise of China given
globalization and the you know the
urgency of climate change allocated all
sorts of problems health poverty issues
you know financial instability the
United States understands it has to
share power now now what we will all
share power with the Chinese but who can
we who can we sit down with to help
design how one shares power and includes
the countries with what with whom one
doesn't have successful and deep
relations well obviously the US and
Europe and Europe when you say Europe
you say Germany yeah but the Americans
are always saying it's it's a constant
cold we hear from Washington that
they're saying to these two the Germans
specifically take more responsibility
that's just that clarion call really
mean you know what a grito it's very
interesting I'm glad you asked because I
was struck you know standing it at the
in Berlin when he gave the speech of
five years ago as somebody who has lived
in this country for many years that here
was it responsibility is always a an
issue because their germany lost the
moral high currents are very aware that
they lost the moral high ground in the
middle of last century and you can
understand many things that happen here
many debates through that prism you can
also understand the over emotionality
the relationship the United States into
Israel and the quickness to criticize
and in some circumstances where it seems
silly or to focus on these two countries
where you know others are should you
look at as well in certain contexts you
know privacy look at France that's one
backdrop to President Obama's visit
another bag drop which we really have to
mention is the fact that it takes place
at the time where we here in Berlin and
marking the 50th anniversary of this bin
ein Berliner I'm a Berliner you are a
Berliner to how important is that it's
very important isn't it's very important
I know that he's looking for I mean
historical examples cases things that
will symbol symbolize his message
whether puts the words in another or not
that's that
the relationship with the Chancellor and
are extraordinarily effective a master
in Germany other reason that is here
okay and because we cannot you know we
got indulge ourselves with insecurities
about this relationship this is a
relationship that has to have results so
he's coming here to make a speech he's
coming here to have working to work and
history will judge this visit not on a
speech but on whether or not Germany in
the United States implement the things
that they discuss okay point taken let's
move on to culture cultural exchange
it's your it's your it's your field it's
your business as it were yeah Americans
have always traveled a lot much more
than many people here in Europe think
they've always been fascinated by
European cities by paris by rome by
london yeah now they're coming to Berlin
in huge numbers culturally and
intellectually what are they looking for
and what are they finding that is such a
good question thank you that's a tough
question well you know what they're
finding is something I was always
skeptical about the myth of Berlin
because they're the when Arthur Miller
came to us I mean 15 years ago in 1998
then television teams would follow him
throughout the city and ask so mr.
Miller 9098 don't you think Berlin is
like New York so Berliners desperately
wanted this city to be cosmopolitan and
erase you know several decades from
their history in fact despite the
Berliners despite the provincial ISM of
the city this city has become
cosmopolitan the new New York well some
people say you know it has the arts
world is analogous to pre the pre-market
moment of New York of the 50s there's no
question about that it's sustainable the
tech scene I never would have believed
this given you know Bavaria and all the
infrastructure I have
um you know business angels people
coming from all of the west coast to
invest in companies to mentor companies
it's extraordinary what's happening the
the European school of management
technologies is focusing on the
management technology this is this city
which has always reinvented itself is
doing so again and you know it's always
in the most liberal of cities in Germany
it's almost almost extraterritorial away
the comparison with New York again there
and let me just ask you about you
personally cuz you're talking yeah okay
Austin Texas yeah your hometown yeah
well let's go back into you you talked
about they're erasing decades of German
history your mother was forced to flee
Germany 1939 I believe as a young girl
six years old I yes had you done any
research yep how do you build a bridge
from that that troubled chapter in your
own personal history to Germany today
the germany and the berlin you see
around you you're really good for
assault is you can imagine i came to
this country for the first time in mid
70 is to start you know first language
courses then i came to the fellowship
program from 70 to 80 then i started
editing books and and doing research and
coming back and forth my mother didn't
come back for 63 years when my son was
bar Mitzvahed in an art deco synagogues
berlin there's still people that don't
come but this is a different place the
reason I'm here and a few others like me
is because they are original motive
given you know the options of teaching
Chicago or being a Dean in New York or
something is that and this sounds you
know well it is the way it sounds is
that to live here as a Jew but not as a
Jew public Jew but is a normal part of
the society and play a role is to die
hit there is victory is to make Germany
into some is to help make Germany to
something else you know I grew up with
you know Yiddish and German with with
you know from Kleist books
more and murica palms this is my culture
I mean when I came here I go to New York
and to and to Jerusalem and to blend or
Frankfurt and and recognized the the
food the the expressions and and the
sort of intellectual perspective the
more the moral perspective so that that
that is what brings people not like me
here and I have changed with this
relationship and grown just as like this
country has grown night the questions I
asked when I came here is 70s and I'm
sure that every you know young German
traveling to Holland into Boston there
ask these questions but the questions
have changed the discussion has changed
I must say fascinating stuff Gary Smith
thank you very much for sharing that
with us today yeah thanks for having me
asking so many tough questions